ELLIE POWERS: Thanks for
the intro, [? Purnima. ?]
So I'm Ellie Powers.
I lead product management
for apps on Google Play.
And I'm really
excited to talk to you
about how to be more successful.
Ever since I joined Google,
this has been a topic
that I'm hugely passionate
about-- helping developers
grow new and
exciting businesses.
So why are we really here?
What is it that
we're trying to do?
Many of us have an
idea or a business
that we're trying to
get out into the world
and that we're trying
to make more successful.
And these days, the best
way to reach people globally
is through building apps,
especially apps on Google Play.
And Michael just talked about
how big that opportunity is.
It's really huge.
And so I want to talk
with you about how
to make those dreams
into a reality
of successful businesses, great
user experiences, and a way
to truly reach people and help
them make their lives more
successful as well.
So one of the themes
that Michael touched on
was how your success
depends a lot
on the quality of
your application.
A great app has
to be functional.
It has to provide
value to a user's life.
It has to solve a real problem
they have, make their day
a little bit more fun,
or things like that.
But on top of that, the app
itself has to be excellent.
And we find that users
have very high expectations
for apps on Play.
So today what we're going to do
is walk through the entire app
development life cycle
and talk about how
you can bring
quality and success
at every step of the way.
So first we're going to start
by talking about design.
And what we've seen from
users on Google Play
is that they have very, very
high expectations for how apps
are going to look and
behave on their devices.
And we hear back from
developers that the time
they spend on optimizing design
pays off many, many times over.
And now with material
design, we're
seeing that Google is
really becoming a leader
in thinking about
how to create great,
delightful, and
engaging experiences
across multiple
types of devices.
So let's get started by digging
deeper into material design.
So what is it, anyway?
It certainly looks
cool, but there's
something much deeper to it.
It's really about defining
the characteristics of how
a UI should feel, move,
and adapt to a user.
We provide design patterns
for how to implement this.
And we try to make this easier
by baking in best practices
for building great touch UIs.
Another theme you'll see coming
up a lot is how to use motion.
But not just for fun--
although for that--
but also to provide
comprehension,
and really going a step
beyond more static web
pages into something
where a user can interact
and understand more deeply.
One of the last
things you'll notice
is that we can use beautiful
aesthetics to not only delight
users, but to also help
designs adapt across screens.
So if you're
interested about this,
I definitely
recommend that you go
to developer.android.com/design.
And there's a bunch of
materials there, and soon
to be more and more
coming, about how
you can start applying
this thinking,
and some technical
concepts to your apps.
So before we dig into the
details of material design,
let's talk a little bit
about what the benefits are.
So first of all,
material design is
great for expressing your brand.
Material design emphasizes
a great use of color
and provides UI patterns that
are sufficiently flexible so
that you can build
experiences that
feel authentic to your
users and the design
that you might have already
across your web, print,
or other products.
Next, material design is really
an opportunity to delight.
It provides great consistency
with the Android experience
so that when a user
is using their device
and using your app as part of
it, it really seems to fit in.
And it also provides
a very strong
cross-platform experience so
that as a user experiences
your device on an Android
tablet, their phone, a website,
it's really a great experience.
And they don't feel like they're
starting over again every time.
And there's a real opportunity
for developers here
who want to be early adopters.
We're offering a new collection
called the Beautiful Design
Collection, and if you're
able to start investing early
in material design, there's
a great opportunity here
to get noticed and
be seen as a leader.
And eventually, material design
will become a requirement
to get featured on Google Play.
OK, so we're going
to take a look
at one app that's
using material design.
We're going to walk
through every step of what
they've done.
All right, so you can see the
old app versus the new app
here.
And we're going to
walk through how
they made each of the changes.
All right, so
here's the old app.
They switched the buddy icons
to the nice circular version.
They added key lines here.
Lots of white space-- it feels
a lot more nicely laid-out.
A bright prop of
color at the top
makes it look really beautiful
and brings out the new Compose
button.
You can see a big
difference here.
And then this new
design will scale easily
to the tablet layout.
OK, let's take a look
at a second example.
So one of the tenets of material
design is to focus on content.
So here you can see the use
of album and artist imagery.
It's a much more visual,
graphic, compelling version
than the smaller image
on the left, which
was the previous design.
We're also making a much
bolder use of color.
You can see here
the bright yellow
that comes from the album
art is drawing your eye.
And we're using a
delightful use of motion
here, not only to make it
feel more fun and interactive,
but also to explain-- as you
kind of dive into one album
or pull back out of it--
how that one album relates
to the rest of the items
in your collection.
Next let's take a look
at the Play Store.
So we can see here that
the Play Store is also
starting to adopt material
design principles.
And one detail I
did want to mention
is material design
isn't just for L.
It also works for
pre-L devices, too,
so you can provide a
consistent experience for all
of your users.
Here the Play Store is
using a bold graphic
across the top of the page.
Many of you who've already
gone to the Developer Console
to update your store
listing have made sure
that you're using that
bold feature graphic.
It does a great job of
expressing the brand
and feeling of the application.
We've also cleaned
up the layout a bunch
and added a nice
white background
with lots of white space so
it doesn't feel as cluttered.
And then in the
center, we have a bunch
of bold, brightly-colored,
geometric icons
that draw the eye as well.
So now we're going to talk
about four different concepts
within material
design so that you
can start thinking about how
to apply them to your apps.
So we're going to talk
about tangible services,
meaningful and
delightful motion,
bold and beautiful aesthetics,
and adaptive design.
And remember, these can
be done in L, of course,
as we all know, but
also on pre-L devices.
There are some new
capabilities that
are coming up in
L that make motion
a lot easier to implement.
OK, so tangible
surfaces-- the idea here
is to use different
surfaces and shadows
and think about how your app,
if it were a physical object,
would actually look and behave.
And the way that something
looks in material design
should make it
easier for the user
to be able to figure out how
the user should interact with it
and how it will respond to them.
Now, these uses of
different surfaces
can be very valuable to
separate the content-- which,
again, in material
design we want
to take the focus-- from
the navigation, which
should be present
but not dominating.
We want to focus
the user's attention
on the most important
parts of the screen.
And the white framing
that we use so commonly
in the material design
layouts makes it easier
to allow the content
to shine, and also
just make the page
look a lot neater.
OK, the second concept
in material design
here is the bold and
beautiful aesthetic.
So again, content
is at the center.
And we love content
that is bold, graphic,
and feels very intentionally
placed on the page.
A lot of material design
examples you'll see as well
will have one primary color,
and then also an accent color.
And we can see the
content providing color,
like the pink heart in
this album art here, too.
The use of typography
is particularly
important in material design.
You can use the fonts that
match best with your brand
and give the right feeling.
And you want to think about
how the fonts fit together
as well with the iconography.
We like geometric icons
in material design.
Now, one of my favorite
things about material design
is this concept of meaningful
and delightful motion.
Everyone wants
technology to be fun.
We all have our
favorite experiences
from when we picked
up a new gadget,
and it just did
something that was fun,
delighted us, and made us laugh.
On the Developer Console,
when you upload new things,
you get a little robot
icon that starts moving,
and we've gotten a lot of
good feedback about that.
But motion can be so much
more meaningful than that.
When people start
using interfaces,
we want to make it
really clear about how
one part of the interface
relates to the next.
And that's what material
design can do with motion.
So when the material
design interface
responds to the user's
touch with motion,
it gives that cue
and that response.
And it draws the eye
naturally, because we
know that motion is really great
for drawing the user's focus.
But you don't want to go
overboard with motion.
The user's action
should be the thing
that initiates the motion.
And also, the motion
should be fast and precise
so that they don't distract
from the interface.
OK, so if we look at the
material design principles,
there's one part I
think that sums it
up pretty well about
what we're trying
to do with adaptive design.
So the idea here is that a
single underlying design system
should organize
interactions and space.
And every device should
reflect a different view
of the same underlying system.
So the idea here is that, for
example, as you can see here,
this is about user's calendar.
And so there's a singular
source of calendar data
from a technical perspective.
But also, visually, the
idea is that there's
sort of a system of rules for
how you display that calendar
information.
And when you look at each device
and what should be surface
there, you should think about
what information and what
presentation is most relevant
and specific to that device.
And then you can use material
design visual elements
to create continuity.
And the margins
and the key lines
may change a bit from
device to device,
but it should feel
consistent and predictable.
So that way, if the user
starts using your app
on a new device-- maybe they
get an Android Wear watch--
they already pretty much have
a good sense of how it should
behave and what it's
able to do for them,
although the watch
will certainly
show a different
view of information
than maybe their laptop
computer, their phone,
or their tablet might have.
OK, so that's material design.
Now let's go on
and talk about how
this applies to certain
types of devices
and what other design concerns
you should think about when
you're trying to build
high-quality apps
across devices.
So last year, we
started a program
called Design for Tablets.
And now we're seeing that the
vast majority of our top apps
already meet all these
Design for Tablets criteria.
And this is fantastic,
because Android tablets
are selling so well.
And we want to make
sure that every user has
a great experience
with every app
that they use on their tablet.
So the idea of a tablet
is really interesting.
And many developers, when
tablets first came out,
thought it was
just a small phone.
But it's so much more than that.
When you have a tablet, you
don't just have more space,
but you have people using
your app in different ways.
So a common thing that
we'll hear from developers
is that people will use their
phone for kind of-- they
called it snacking,
frequently going and getting
a little bit of information,
doing one, small, short task.
But with the tablet,
it's not like a snack.
It's more like a meal.
People will sit down with
their tablet and interact
much more deeply.
So in addition to thinking
about what type of visual layout
you want to have-- and you
can use Fragments to build
flexible UIs that adapt very
easily across different device
sizes-- you also want to think
about what functionality you
should offer for
the best experience.
So then, when you think that
you've designed a great tablet
app, you want to make sure that
you upload it to the Google
Play Developer
Console, and that you
check the Design for
Tablets checklist
to make sure it's
met all the criteria.
And the reason why
this is important
is that if you want your app to
be fully visible and incredibly
prominent on Google
Play, it needs
to make sure that it
meets all these criteria.
If you're browsing
apps on your tablet
and you go to the
top charts, the ones
that you'll see by
default are the ones
that meet the Design
for Tablets criteria.
And so you want to make
sure that your app is
going to be visible there.
So if you check the checklist,
you'll know what to do.
Another great thing to do is
you want to explain to the user
exactly how the app will
work on their device.
And a picture is worth
a thousand words,
so that's why we give
you the opportunity
to upload seven-inch
and 10-inch tablet
screenshots in the
Developer Console.
So that way, when
someone browses your app
in Google Play on
a tablet, they'll
see the screenshots that really
represent how your app is going
to look on their device, and any
tablet specifically [INAUDIBLE]
and features that you have.
So if you want to
then start thinking
about how to go above and
beyond the basic criteria,
I definitely recommend that
you go to developer.android.com
and check out our tablet
quality checklist for some more
explanations about how to
have a truly great Android
app on tablets.
OK, so next we're going to
talk more about Android Wear.
So if you're not sure
how to get started,
the most important thing
to think about first
is there's actually
three possible ways
that your app can
adapt to Android Wear.
First of all, step one,
there's the no work option.
Notifications will just
show up automatically.
Step two, you can
spend a bit more work
to enhance these notifications.
Or step three, you
have the option
of building a much more
complex application.
We're going to walk
through all three of these.
So first, the most
basic thing to know
is if your app
creates notifications,
they'll automatically
just start showing up
by default on someone's
Android Wear device.
You'll probably want
to check it out just
to be sure that you're
happy with the experience.
But this shouldn't imply
any extra work for you
as long as you're using
standard notifications.
So second is the idea of
enhancing these notifications.
And this is a really
great option to consider.
Because usually it'll take
maybe 10 lines of code or so.
But then you can
make an experience
that gives really big benefits.
So there's a couple of cool
things you can do here.
By default, if you
have a messaging app,
those notifications
with new messages
will show up on the Wear device.
But it's really easy
to add a voice reply
so that the user can respond
directly from the Wear device
without having to
unlock their phone
and take it out of their pocket.
There are also
other ways to format
the enhanced notifications,
like pages and stacking,
that might be worth looking into
depending on what type of app
you have.
So for those of you who are
really looking to be innovators
and to push into
new areas, I want
to give you a couple tips
for building a full Wear app.
So on the left, we have
kind of the default software
development schedule
that most of us
think that we're going to have.
So for example, we think we'll
spend a little bit of time
on design, we'll
build the thing,
and then we'll spend a little
bit of time debugging it.
But what usually
ends up happening
is we need more design
time than we thought,
and the debugging
process isn't so speedy.
Now, specifically for
Android Wear applications,
the recommendation
that we're seeing
based on some of our
earliest access partners
is you're going to
probably think about 25%
of your time for UX iteration.
And so why is that?
The old rules don't
apply in Android Wear.
A lot of us have experience
building web pages,
probably apps for
the phone, maybe
apps for the tablet as well.
But Android Wear is totally
new, and a different interaction
modality may be necessary.
So if you put in the time,
and you spend time iterating,
it can be really fun to explore.
And you can end up with
something that's amazing.
And if someone is carrying your
app around on their wrist 24/7,
that's a really
unique opportunity.
And I think it warrants
the investment.
OK, now we're going to
talk more about Android TV
and how to build great apps.
So the types of apps
that we see as being
most promising in the living
room are games and media apps.
And the way to think about
the TV is this, right?
This is not like putting
a gigantic computer
in your living room.
It's not even like putting a
gigantic mobile phone or tablet
in your living room.
It's really a
different experience.
The user wants to lean
back, sit on the sofa,
and be entertained.
So put content at the center.
And secondly, you want to create
something that's immersive.
So go ahead and use movement,
sound, and visual imagery
to create something
that has a truly
cinematic experience if you can.
And, perhaps most
importantly, we definitely
recommend that you simplify.
If a person's using a
remote control to interact,
and they just want
to sit down and put
on their favorite
program, you don't
want to send them
through menu after menu.
You just want to put the fewest
screens and least friction
between the user and the content
that they want to engage with.
So we offer you some
lean back themes
and other TV-optimized
layouts to try
to make building a TV
app as easy as possible.
And if you're interested, we
actually have a program where
you can go online to
developer.android.com/TV
and request an
ADT1 developer kit.
This will help you get
started and actually test
your TV app on something real.
OK, so we talked
about how design
is the great first
building block for having
a high-quality and
successful app.
So now we're going
to talk about how
to take this same
idea of quality
and to bring it through next
to the development process.
OK, so Michael mentioned
earlier the Android L release.
We have material design, the
most new APIs of any release,
and a bunch of cool user
features like better task
switching, faster app
runtimes, and so forth.
I'm really excited about
the improved battery life
and also how it's designed
to help handle flaky network
connections.
So those of us who
tend to get dropped
calls are going to have
a better experience.
So I want to walk through
just a couple things
that you should think about
when you're thinking about how
to have a high-quality,
engaging, successful experience
on L. And the first
one is notifications.
So immediately what you'll
notice about what's different
for notifications in L
is the background color.
It used to be black.
Now they have a white color.
And you actually get to change
the little blue dot color there
that appears next to each
of your notifications.
So if you want to express your
brand there and capitalize
on your material
design layout, this
is a great place to pick it.
The second thing that you
should know about and check
in your app is that
we're allowing users
to modify all of their
global notification settings
through the Android
Settings app.
So just make sure that you
add a notifications flag
to the manifest to make sure
that your app will appear there
in the settings so that
users can go there to adjust
notifications for your app
from the central location.
And then finally, one really
cool thing that we're doing
is we're starting to
show notifications
on the lock screen.
So as we all know, once a user
installs your app, that's cool.
But you want to keep
them engaged over time.
And the lock screen
is a new area
to bring up things
that are very critical
and a user needs to notice.
And you also want to be
really sensitive here, too.
If a user has, let's say, a
messaging app on their phone,
and you receive a new
message, and you're
going to show it to
them, they may not
want to see the contents of that
message on their lock screen,
right?
Someone else might
pick up their phone
and go, well, that's
very interesting.
So you need to think about
what sort of private, public,
and secret views you want to
have of different notifications
to make sure that if things are
showing up on the lock screen,
it's meeting users' expectations
and still being helpful.
OK, so let's talk
a little bit more
about how we can take care of
the Android One opportunity
and make the most
of the opportunity
for emerging markets.
So one of the key things
that we hear again and again
about emerging markets is
that data plans are expensive,
and only lower-end
smartphones may be available.
So these are the
devices that you're
going to be dealing with.
And what we find for
most developers who
invest in those areas
is once they learn
how to build their apps
right, they actually
get massive benefits today.
And we forecast only greater and
greater growth tomorrow there.
So let's talk about
a couple of things
you can do to optimize your app.
So first of all,
for the network,
just assume that your user
is going to be on 2G only.
And so what does this mean?
Longer latency,
slower loading times.
So you'll want to make
sure that you don't just
try to load the data and
time out after 10 seconds.
You might need to assume that
some of those attempts to load
data aren't going to work.
Make sure that the
user is messaged
when data is or isn't loading.
And make sure that
your application
doesn't have
dependencies on having
consistent, continuous
network connection.
Second, optimizing for lower
memory on lower-end devices
is really important, and
again will pay off hugely.
So in Android Studio,
we have a new function
called Memory Monitor.
And this can help you understand
the memory profile of your app
and identify areas
to improve it.
And third, the thing that I
can't say enough is just test.
We offer an emulator.
Some people use physical
devices as well.
And this allows you to do those
memory and network simulations.
So if you have a physical
device and you're
trying to test there,
try switching off Wi-Fi,
setting your device
to use only 2G,
and try to simulate
the connections
that your users will see.
And if you think this
is really exciting--
because I definitely do-- we
have a recent post from Sundar
Pichai on her official Android
blog talking about some
of the opportunities
here for developers.
And I definitely recommend
that you check it out.
OK, so if there are any
software developers here,
we hope that you're trying
out new Android Studio Beta.
And if you're not, I
wanted to highlight
a couple of the key features
that we've released recently.
We talked a ton about how
one of the big pushes right
now is around supporting
for new device types
and what the new opportunities
are to be early adopters.
And Android Studio Beta can
really help you with that.
They provide a bunch of
templates and other support,
so it's not that hard to
take an existing phone app
and to figure out how to extend
it onto new device types.
It also offers
the Memory Monitor
that I mentioned earlier.
And if you're adding Google
Play services or other types
of Google services,
this is the easiest way
to set up the integration.
So it's no hassle to add
Google Analytics, Maps,
or other capabilities.
It also offers a nice,
rich layout editor.
So you can set up
different themes,
and your app will look
much nicer by default.
And it has a lot of
quality improvement tools
around usability issues, version
compatibility, and stability.
Cool, so definitely recommend
you guys try that out too.
I also wanted to mention
Google Cloud Platform.
Today, all of our
apps are definitely
connected to back-end storage.
And I wanted to tell you
about this opportunity here.
So whenever you're
launching a new app,
you want to be ready
for big growth.
But you probably don't have
a huge budget to invest.
So we have this thing that we
call the mobile starter kit.
And what it allows
you to do is to have
a small financial investment.
But then if your
app goes really big,
you'll be able to
immediately take
advantage of all of the
best of Google's network.
So super-fast for
performance, and it also
supports cross-platform mobile
apps, as well as the web,
so that you can use this
across your entire offering.
And Google Play
services launched
two new functionalities
earlier in the year.
If you're not using
it already, we
want you to know
that this is the best
way to integrate any
APIs from Google,
whether that's
the In-app Billing
API, Google Maps, or more.
And the great thing
about it, too,
is that this is something
that's kept up-to-date by Google
on the user's device.
So immediately, without having
to integrate any new SDK,
the new features are available
across all of your users
immediately.
So the two new things that
we announced this year
are the activity
recognition API can now
recognize running and walking.
So those of you
with fitness apps
might be able to
make use of that.
And we also
announced Cloud Save.
So a key user challenge
is to make sure
that when they have
data in their app,
they can expect it to be saved
and made available across all
of their devices-- their
phone, their tablet,
maybe the web,
maybe their watch.
And the Cloud Save
API makes this
easy with no
back-end programming.
It also does a really
good job of handling syncs
when a user transitions between
offline and online modes.
So if you want to make sure
your app works really well,
definitely check that out.
OK, so we talked about how
to bring quality and success
to the development process.
And now we're going to talk
about the final stage--
distribution-- and
how you can make sure
that your app has
maximum success on Play
at this final step.
So we talked already about
beautiful material design
in Play and how we've
revamped the storefront.
But rather than focusing
on the visual aspects,
now I want to talk
about the functionality
that this provides to
you as a developer.
So this store listing
page on the Play Store
is basically your shop window.
And this is how people
evaluate whether or not
they want to install your app.
We've tried to make it
optimized so it gives people
a great experience.
And also it gives
you the opportunity
to express your brand.
So across the top, you see here
there's a big banner graphic.
And it can be really
beautiful and express whatever
you want about your app.
If you haven't already, make
sure you go to the Developer
Console and provide that image.
We also provide a short
summary at the bottom where
you can highlight
some of the key things
that your app provides,
a summary of it in one
or two sentences.
And then in the
middle of the page,
we tell the user about
different reasons
to install their app, like the
number of ratings that it has,
if it's a high rating, a lot
of installs, their friends
have recommended it, perhaps.
And we're also thinking
about other ways
that maybe we can allow
developers to share more
in the Play Store.
So one of the most
important things
we hear developers talk
about is app ratings.
And we find in the
Play Store that users
use this as a huge
tool for evaluating
which app to install.
If I'm picking between
two different apps that
do basically the same thing,
the one with the better ratings
will obviously get more traffic.
So this is a great tool for
making users compare the apps
and pick your app favorably.
So as you see the quality
of your app increase,
the ratings should
increase as well.
But in addition,
there's actions that you
can take as a developer to make
sure that your ratings are even
more successful, and to also
use this as an opportunity
to reach out to your users.
So you can go into
the Developer Console
today and reply
to user comments.
So what happens when you
reply to one of these comments
is that user receives
an email message,
unless they've opted out.
And also, your response is
displayed in the Play Store.
And what we found
from developers
who have been using this
feature for the past couple
years is they get great
feedback from users.
A user didn't expect
to receive a response.
But they're delighted when
a developer says, hey,
thanks for reporting that issue.
We're going to fix it
in the next version.
And sometimes
developers even find
that users say,
wow, you're right.
You did actually fix my bug.
Or you explained to me how
that feature in your app works.
And so they'll actually
go back and sometimes
end up improving their review
and improving their opinion
over time.
So now we're going to talk about
why we launched beta testing
and staged rollouts.
So developers
would often tell us
that when you make your
debut on the Play Store,
it's critical to make sure that
it's working great on day one.
Otherwise, users will
leave bad reviews,
and it's hard to
recover from that.
So we wanted to make sure that
you can integrate quality user
feedback from the beginning, so
that when you make your debut,
it's not the first time
anyone's tried your app.
But rather, your app has been
well tested throughout time.
So we want you to first
launch strong, and then
be able to keep
your momentum going.
We've been overwhelmed by
the response to beta testing
and staged rollout over
the past year and a half.
We've had now over 80,000
apps using these features,
getting an average
rating of 4.2 stars.
And we've also seen that
over 1/3 of our top apps
are using beta testing today.
And many of them are using
staged rollouts, too.
So we're recommending
beta testing
and staged rollouts as a best
practice for all developers.
So let's go through
each of these concepts
and how you can apply them.
So the purpose of
beta testing is
to be able to
release your app just
to a small, select group of
power users who you choose.
So what this means is you
can control the access,
and you can also
keep it private so
that your super-stealth app
doesn't end up in the press
before you expect it.
And users who want to
participate in beta tests
need to opt in.
And they're also blocked
from leaving reviews
so that you don't end up
leaking any new features
or end up with low reviews as a
result of buggy beta software.
We also now give you
statistics so you can easily
compare how your new
beta and alpha versions
are doing against your
production versions.
And so that way
you can make sure
that things are trending up
and to the right over time.
We found best practice
was from developers
to solicit as much user
feedback as possible.
Sometimes they do
this within the app.
Sometimes the users use a Google
group or Google+ community
to get this feedback.
But either way, we
found that developers
who are most open and
responsive to this feedback
end up with the best results.
And some developers
have also told us
that they use this
as an early preview
to get metrics about how their
users might perform in the app
and production.
Although you have
to keep in mind
that a group of power
users may or may not
represent your full user base.
So after you've done an
alpha test, a beta test,
and you're feeling
confident, you're
able to release your
app to production.
And when you push new versions
of your app to production,
you're able to
control the rollout
to just a percentage of users.
And these users are
randomly selected, including
both new users and
existing users who
might receive the
staged rollout version.
And staged rollouts
are visible publicly,
and users can also
leave reviews.
The purpose of a staged rollout
is that you should already
be pretty confident in
what you're pushing,
but it just gives you
that extra level of safety
where if something unexpected
happens-- like maybe a bug that
didn't show up in
earlier testing-- then
it doesn't impact all the users.
And it ends up having a
positive impact on reviews.
Because you can catch this
before it hits everybody.
OK, so as developers, we
don't have a lot of time.
And something that I hear
frequently time and time
again is, well, what
should I focus on?
There's like 100
things I can do.
They all might improve my
app, but I'm not really sure.
We also want to go from
offering a bunch of data
to developers to offering
clear, highly-tailored insights,
things that were going
to help your app.
So the idea behind
optimization tips and alerts
is to do exactly this.
We offer a wide variety of
optimization tips and alerts.
So they cover
everything from how
to design your app for tablets,
when and how to localize
your app, and to make sure
you're upgrading to the latest
version of APIs, like
the In-app Billing API.
We also got some good feedback
from developers earlier
when we started offering alerts
for when something goes wrong.
So for example, maybe you pushed
out a new version of your app.
But actually, the reviews are a
lot worse than the old version.
So we'll let you know.
And developers told us,
well, that's really helpful.
But couldn't you just get
that information to me
as soon as possible?
And so that's why
this year we made it
so that you can now sign up to
receive these alerts via email
so that you find out right
away and can fix the problem
before more users
have a bad experience.
So once you understand kind
of how your app is generally
doing, you want to start
looking inside your app
and see what users
are doing inside.
And so Google Analytics is a
really easy way to do this.
And it also allows you to
compare behavior and see
how users move between the web
and also different mobile apps,
even on cross-platforms
outside of Android.
So Google Analytics is actually
available through Google Play
Services.
So this has a few benefits.
First of all, you don't have
to add another SDK to your APK
and bloat its size.
You only have to add
a few lines of code.
And it also comes for
free if you're already
using AdMob in your app.
And so once you
understand what users
are doing inside your
app, the next step
is to start running
experiments to see
how you can get users to engage
more, spend more, and have more
fun.
So Google Tag Manager is an
easy way of running experiments.
And it integrates
with Google Analytics.
So the idea is that you set
up a goal-- maybe the amount
of money that a user spends,
or maybe the amount of time
that a user spends in an app,
or the number of videos watched.
And then you set up multiple
versions of your app.
Maybe one version has
a the blue background,
one has a red background.
Or maybe it's more
sophisticated than that.
And then you say, optimize
these different versions
towards the goal.
So over time, it'll run
these different versions,
see what the user behavior
is towards the goal,
and automatically move
users over to whatever
version ends up winning.
So it's a really
easy way to make sure
that you have an optimal
experience inside your app.
So another question
we get from developers
a lot is, how can I understand
the whole conversion funnel?
If I'm running a particular
marketing campaign,
how do I understand how many
people are looking at my app
in the Play Store, how many
people are installing it,
and then how many people
are actually running it?
So last year, we announced
the Google Play Referral Flow
Report.
This is available
in Google Analytics.
And so it helps you
do exactly that.
And the purpose here is to
be able to understand which
user acquisition
channels-- like maybe which
ad campaigns or other
things-- are most effective.
Because again, you might
have some installs happening,
but you really care
about which users go on
to become users of the app.
So we've seen now, as
developers are becoming
more sophisticated in
how the currency of apps
is really engagement over the
long term rather than just
a one-time install,
developers are focusing more
on tracking the most
meaningful segments of users,
whatever users are most
engaged with their business.
So for example,
if I had a game, I
would be able to use Google
Analytics to track user
segments to maybe
say, let me look
at users who came in
through a certain campaign.
Maybe they've gotten to
level seven in my game,
and they've spent more than $5.
OK, and then one of the things
we've seen on businesses
is that more and
more developers are
running hugely successful, very
profitable businesses on Play.
And we're trying
to do everything
that we can to scale their
expertise to everybody,
and to make it easier to
measure your businesses,
whether you're a small startup
or a much larger company
with a dedicated analytics team.
So we offer the Google
Play Revenue Report,
which offers not only
your total revenue,
but has been recently
updated to include
the average revenue per paying
user, the number of buyers.
And you can even
see easy breakdowns
by different countries.
So you can see how your
business is growing
into each of those
different markets.
In response to feedback from
a bunch of our developers
who had a lot of apps
or published their apps
in a lot of
countries, we're also
offering the developer
publishing API.
So if you're a developer
with, let's say,
100 apps, and each of those
apps is offered in 50 languages,
and you've uploaded
all of the text,
and all of the
tablet screenshots,
and all the banners, for all
those different languages,
it becomes kind of a
multiplicative problem.
And so we thought, we
can do better than that.
So we now have an API that you
can use to manage your APKs,
the text for your store
listing, the graphics
for your store listing.
And you can also manage
your in-app product
catalog and alpha
and beta tests.
You're able to integrate this
with whatever build system
that your company
has so that you
can take those assets directly
from where they are already
on your servers and in
your development process
and push them directly
into the Developer Console
and into Google Play without
a bunch of copy and paste.
So if you have a really
big operation like this,
we definitely recommend
that you check this out,
although we definitely
want to see you coming back
to the Developer Console to
get a lot more of the analytics
and insights and see
how your app is doing.
OK, so today, we had
an overview of how
we can make our app
more successful,
and how to build high quality
across all the different stages
of the software
development process.
So in the area of design, we
looked into material design
and how to adapt to new devices.
We looked then at development.
We talked about how
the L release offers
some new, beautiful
experiences for users
and what you'll need to
do to update your app
to make it ready for L.
There's new tools
available at Android Studio
to help you do that.
And also, if you're looking
at building a lot of success
in emerging markets, Android
One and network and battery
optimizations are
a great way to go.
And then finally, we looked
at how you can make sure
your app is high
quality as you get
started in distribution
through beta testing
and staged rollouts.
And then we also looked at
how to bring more analytics
and insight into your users
through the optimization tips
and Google Analytics
integration.
So I hope that this will
be a good day for you
as we go on into later
sessions to understand more
about business and localization.
And thanks again for
being part of Google Play.
When someone gets a
new device, yes, they
want to have a device.
But what they really
are looking for
is great software,
great apps that
really bring the device to life.
So thanks again for building
such fantastic, beautiful,
high-quality apps.
And we wish you luck
with material design,
and the L, and all the
next chapters on Play.
Thanks.